we certainly hope you all had a Happy
Thanksgiving with lots of delicious
feasting with family and friends before
we get to the rest of the show go around
the table so you have everyone's
Thanksgiving was I think we'll have to
start with you Greg it was great
the producers asked us if we would
supply pictures okay so I did so we this
is the turkey ha ha and then that's a
bowl of stuffing stuffing is great
actually what I like Lawrence I went off
on my Atkins diet and had some stuffing
there were some green beans which were
delicious and we had some corn on the
cob I was at a restaurant they serve
corn on the cob on things well it was
like sliced it was at a restaurant and I
think I have a picture of me and the
people I was with you can see there's
Sean Tucker and me and we're just
enjoying a nice meal it's a this is what
we do outside of work that looks very
yes looks very fun Lawrence you were in
Dallas yes so I cooked a lot of this
stuff my mom had lupus growing up and so
she taught me how to cook very early so
I cook a lot of my family got together
and talked politics actually and we it
didn't plan that way because my mom had
already said none of that
that's a pecan pie but we talked about
it was very civil it was a civil
conversation nobody will scream it at
each other I mean we can actually talk
loud but you know you're showing
pictures of the food that you made you
know my mother is 92 oh she's sharp as a
tack and she and I and a friend went out
to a hotel and my mother had whatever
she wanted with the active support and
love of her son it was the right kind of
thanks giving thanks for asking she did
and I felt proud and we're thankful this
is your first time on the 5 yeah and my
mother is I hope watching but thank you
mom for everything and thank you for all
the love and support that you've given
me widget which in does she still have a
cocktail or she has a cocktail whenever
she wants with my support and love
that's exactly
exactly what's your choice our cocktail
of choice is Prosecco the only thing she
says to me is how did you as a centrist
turn out as you did because she's far
left and it was good we cooked it was
the first time that we cooked my husband
Pinot Turkey there's my husband with the
turkey he actually did for his first
Turkey it was delicious I don't know
what he did to it cuz I wasn't part of
that part but my dog was there she had
so much food she ate turkey sweet potato
applesauce that's my angel and I made a
gluten-free stuffing that I was
terrified was gonna be awful that was
actually delicious to do that because
you have issues with gluten or oh here
we go
[Laughter]
yes I had steak I had a rib eye that was
was so good and there was nothing
gluten-free about it well I took a bunch
of pictures of my dog but I think we
have those he was out there this is the
table we were edgy and we my mom and her
friend barb are here in town and Peter
and I we all went to the Yacht Club and
then we joined on with the Landers
family they have a big family and we
have a small little family so we got to
be a part of them so that was really fun
pictures of my dog what's the
interesting fact I told you today about
the yacht there is no C the C is silent
in yacht yes isn't that interesting we
watched our facebook live you too could
have had that before and you can you can
win these pictures yes you can win these
pictures guessing what I'm thinking up
right now to get back on the diet now
yesterday was the cheap I'm jealous of
you Lauren yeah 51 pounds 11 today to
celebrate you eat whatever you want you
adore your family and then you go back
on it today
so you gonna buy a bunch of new clothes
yeah I'm doing that Black Friday
shopping yeah
well we have a lot of get to even though
I would like to talk about Thanksgiving
but we have to move on to the border
battle that's heating up president Trump
threatening to shut down the entire
border if Mexico doesn't control the
migrant Caravan headed our way we find
that it's it gets to a level where we
are going to lose control or our people
are going to start getting hurt we will
close entry into the country for a
period of time until we can get it under
control
I've already shut down parts of the
border because it was out of control
with the rioting on the other side could
there be a shutdown there certainly
could and it will be about border
security of which the wall is apart the
president also says he's authorizing
active duty troops at the border to use
force if they have to this has Trump
warns of a government shutdown if
Congress doesn't move on funding the
wall the former acting ice director also
urging lawmakers to secure the border
now or else he says the situation will
get worse the reason there's a caravan
on the border the reason the borders the
numbers are high right now is Congress
has failed to act they failed to build a
wall they have failed to close the
loopholes out of Collins it's causing
these caravans everybody's watching
what's going on right now and if we do
not secure this border if these if we
let these people come in and they get
released not to show up on chlorine if
they show up in the court get ordered
don't leave if we don't have a hard
response and protect the sovereignty of
this country right now there's gonna be
more caravans this is just the beginning
alright so an agreement I was saying
that I have this sense I can see the
future that this issue is coming to a
head and it's going to get solved
Congress is going to have to do
something
Lawrence you talked about immigration at
the Thanksgiving table yeah we talked
about immigration and the only issue
that my family pretty much agrees with
Trump on is immigration my grandmother
made it very clear she was like son I
may not like Donald Trump the one thing
I will do is help him build that wall
and a lot of black folks agree when it
comes to the issue because freedom has
never been something that is free
there's something that you fight for
there's blood in the soil of people that
fought for that and that's how a lot of
Americans see it now we talked about
this earlier in your show will Congo
get it done I don't think so because
both political parties benefit from this
controversy
the president has caved on the issue a
little bit he said look I'll give you
citizenship for daca people but as far
as the parents coming across here they
got to go through the process I'm gonna
secure the board and I don't think
Democrats are willing to cave because of
the optics of the wall even though they
many of them previously had the position
of supporting the wall a lot of them
don't support it now I think we
Democrats would benefit from a
compromise yeah do border security do
the wall do Daka and try to get a
pathway to citizenship because this is
issues hurt the Democrats and it's clear
would help the Republicans do because
look Trump made the whole campaign about
immigration about the caravan it didn't
do so well in the congressional
elections and for him to broaden his
appeal for 2020 a deal would help them
my advice in the lame-duck session start
the process of getting it done tie it to
criminal justice reform will be even
better
that's gonna be tough to get an
immigration done and I could lame-duck
yeah but we got a trial because
ultimately it'll be tougher for the
Republicans after the new Congress is
sworn in with Nancy Pelosi that's true
I'm an optimist I feel like something
could get done Jedidiah but these guys
are telling me is gonna be tough here an
I mean this was the chief issue that
President Trump ran on and one of the
reasons he got elected was immigration
the people thought he was gonna be tough
on that he talked about the wall
extensively so I think if there's an
issue for him to really hit home on and
and really look if you if you got to
shut the government down I know people
on the left and some people on the right
freaked out when you talk about a
government just gets to the left yeah
but not necessarily because no you know
why it's a gift to the left because they
market it well because they they don't
talk about the fact that so many
essential government services actually
continue when you have a guy like the
tide is turning on it though Greg like
you see the pictures every day we've
been taught we talk about this issue
every single day for years and it feels
like to me like it's coming to a head
and might get it to a good place
well I'm a little pessimistic as well
it's it's obvious that for Donald Trump
this is a central concern of his that
has long-term benefits in his head but
has a short-term cost
you don't get good PR the media hates
you you're painted as a bigot there are
all these short-term consequences to a
long term benefit which is that you're
the changes in the immigration is is not
being kept up with the current system so
you have to make we update our phone
every year we have a system that we
refuse to update for fear of being
yelled at so it's it show it immigration
highlights the difference differences
between the constrained and
unconstrained conservatives are
constrained they believe humans are
fallible there and will gain the system
so you need to have a process but the
left unconstrained believe in moral
progress and that laws are just
temporary and so the answer is not moral
progress it's political benefit if Trump
is flexible on what the wall is and the
Democrats are flexible on terms for daca
and a pathway to citizenship the big
winner will be Donald Trump because
he'll be able to say where your base is
your base the progressive wing of the
party I'm not but I'm telling your party
that's not where the energy of your
party is right sadly you know a lot of
those people are open border for gray
are and that's all you have to please
those Pino you don't have to please your
ship is done because she's fighting for
re-election right now she's reelected
that's done she doesn't have the full
support of her caucus does now and
they're gonna saw her in chairmanships
and all those other commitments not well
and so with that base of the party how
are you gonna set them up you're not and
so we just need to get the Republicans
to do a deal that will benefit from
benefit the Democrats and benefits of
you know how this works Doug right right
but they're gonna say oh yeah you know
let's talk about a path to citizenship
and then once this is all figured out we
have comprehensive immigration reform
then we can talk about border security I
say flip it dirty
dude you're you're right Janet I gotta
be border security first I'm gonna make
one last point and then we'll go it's
just that if both sides benefit from it
politically from it being an issue why
can't the same be true that both sides
would benefit from it getting salt
because you're leaving out one central
piece and that is the media which
benefits from playing Santa and it goes
back to the short-term
consequences which is you can call Trump
a racist you can call conservatives
bigots and you can ignore the long term
benefits which is that this will make
the country safer and better to have an
immigration system that matches the
current challenges it's hard to be the
adult yeah that's what what we're
dealing with right now talking about
walls and talking about immigration
that's the adult filter the media has
the child filter which is like this is
just mean that's the challenge I'd say
we want to do a deal then then you think
the media won't today okay well then
like they will support them and trying
to get that done I think they will do
that if they actually be get the White
House and then all of a sudden they
become adults have tried that in 2008
Obama should try it again now it'll help
the Democrats oh we got to talk about
this like it Lawrence's Thanksgiving
table